ADAM GLAZIER: Hi,
I'm Adam Glazier,
a UX designer on the
Google Cast team.
If you're new to
Cast, Cast is a way
for people to get content
from your app to their TV.
And in this video,
I'll show you why
Cast works the way
it does so that you
can be informed while
designing your app.
Now for the sake of
simplicity, the examples
I'll share focus on casting
and controlling video.
However, it's worth
noting that you can also
cast other types of media, such
as music, games, and photos.
Now, when designing
for Cast, there
are three main
things to consider.
Your app is the remote.
So just like a TV
remote, your app
should make it easy for anyone
to control a cast at any time.
People need instant
control no matter
what state their device is in.
Second, it's a
shared experience.
When your app is casting, expect
that others are in the room.
Some will be watching.
Some will contribute.
And some will need
to take control.
Third is that it's
cross platform.
The living room has
many devices in it,
and the more devices that
can control your cast,
the more seamless it will feel.
Now because casting's
a new action,
its usage depends
on people being
reminded that it's available.
An easy way to do this is
to show a one time cast
introduction screen.
This intro will help
users new to casting
and also help
experienced users know
that your app is
now cast enabled.
So placing the cast
icon at the top right
of every screen in
your app will allow
users to start and
control casts at any time.
And to be clear, the
cast icon should always
be visible whenever a cast
receiver is available.
Now, once users
are ready to cast,
they can do that in two ways.
They can connect to a cast
receiver and then play content,
or they can start
playing content
and then connect to a receiver.
Either way they start, cast
is the mode of the app.
So just like Bluetooth,
once you're connected,
whatever you play in the
app should cast to the TV.
Now once content starts
streaming to the TV,
the phone allows users
to browse and control
casts while the TV displays
the streaming content.
Now, when designing
your TV UI, do not
make it look touchable or
simply reuse the tablet UI.
For example, in
research I've observed,
people attempted to use
the physical TV remote
when the UI on the TV
looked interactive.
So with this in mind, when
you tap pause on the phone,
it changes to a play icon and
the TV shows to pause icon.
This is because the
TV's showing the state
and the phone is
providing the action.
The second tip is to help the
TV UI stay out of the way.
For instance, people
will sometimes
pause a video to examine
a frame or read text
on the screen like
closed captions.
So when someone pauses a
video, fade the TV UI away
after five seconds.
Keeping the UI within the
lower fourth of the TV
will also help since most
of the important content
is typically above that.
The last tip is to
provide the ability
to control a cast from
every state of your app.
At any given time, the most
critical controls for people
are play and pause and volume.
Remember, this is
super important,
because your app is the
only remote they have.
Now, on Android, there's five
places to surface controls.
You can provide a full set
of controls in your app
for the content
currently playing
and when navigating
elsewhere in your app,
provide a persisting controller.
This is commonly a control bar
at the bottom of every screen.
Also, provide controls
within the cast menu,
because this is where users
start and stop casting.
And when users
exit your app, make
sure to provide controls
and notifications
in the lock screen.
Doing all of these together
will ensure the most seamless
experience so that your
users can relax and use
their phone however they like.
Now, once something's
casting, expect
that more users will
want to join in.
So at a minimum, when
multiple users are connected,
each user should be
able to take control.
An example of this
is that if you
left the room while
casting, your friend
should be able to take control.
Another possibility is that you
started a cast and your friends
want to add to the queue.
So designing your app to
work for anyone at any time
will help it feel extra natural.
Now, from time to time, expect
that the phone's connection
to a cast may go in and out.
This can happen from the
Wi-Fi going out of range,
the phone battery dying, or
your app's processes being
stopped by another app.
When this happens,
automatically reconnect
users that dropped off
whenever they're in your app.
The final step to a
cast is disconnecting.
Users can disconnect
from the cast menu
and also from a
notification in Android.
Now, to prevent users from
accidentally stopping a cast,
make sure to only
stop the cast when
the last connected
user disconnects.
For the complete set
of cast UX guidelines,
don't forget to check out the
design checklist on the cast
SDK site.
Thanks for watching, and
I'll see you next time.